i love that you came to my house and you
broke up with me in my space and then
when i think about that every time i'm
here that's great that is so perfect for
me it's the best thing that's around
here
where else was i supposed to do it
because you won't come to my house oh
here he is the puppet master is back but
i'm not i'm not no i'm not the puppeteer
you're doing this to me it's true you
won't come to my house so my apartment
looks like two rats just in it every day
oh right like thank you for that i'm a
[ __ ] thank you
where is he
stanley oh
what's going on oh come on i know you've
been cheating on me you're being
ridiculous andrea enough is enough i
know you have been
a dog behind my back
what
a dog a dog that is insane then why did
i find this in the laundry room
oh my god
he's here right now isn't he he's in my
house right now
stanley no wait
oh
oh
oh
i see
you
need to know
your dog
ruined a 10-year marriage
and you
can go to hell
oh he's cute he's cute i can see why you
like him
so what do you want to do tonight like i
was thinking maybe we can meet up with
amy and brad and like before that we
could go to angelo's and before that we
could like just go buy vegan
i have something to say
i had to say it in person
because it's
it's like super important
okay
um
i know this is sudden
but like i've been thinking about this
for a while
[Music]
and i know this is something that needs
to happen
i'm breaking up with you
cool love it totally fine with that
really yeah
cause i thought
i was i was really worried that you're
gonna be like mad
mad
oh my god are you kidding me
no
of course i'm not mad people grow apart
it happens it's like part of life no i'm
totally fine like love it love it love
it
um
so
uh um you know we we had a good run
[Music]
don't be a stranger
can i just
i ask why
why
yeah like what i was like i'm doing some
work on myself and like trying to grow
as a person so i really like appreciate
to know why
yeah um
okay yeah that's like you know i think
that you're kind of like a controlling
person thank you
thank you for that that's nice thank you
for attack
cool no problem yeah
so you know what your problem is andre
what
you keep tabs on people
every little thing somebody does you
have to keep a tab of it
wait i i
i can't tell if you're angry or not i'm
not
i'm totally not angry oh no i'm excited
it's good it's just like you said your
piece
and i just think that i deserve the
human decency to say my peace right
right is that
is that not okay no no no it's
no of course of course
you're a controlling manipulative person
everyone says it
i i i don't think that i am yes you are
andre yes
okay now like you sound pretty i'm not
angry
i'm not angry i'm fine i love it i love
that you came to my house and you broke
up with me in my space and then when i
think about that every time i'm here
that's great that is so perfect for me
it's the best thing around here
where else was i supposed to do it
because you won't come to my house oh
wait here he is the puppet master is
back but i'm not i'm not no i'm not the
puppeteer you're doing this to me it's
true you won't come to my house so my
apartment looks like two rats just in it
every day oh right like thank you for
that i'm a [ __ ] thank you i didn't know
i didn't say [ __ ] i didn't always say
isn't it am i evil or am i a [ __ ] no no
you're not evil vegan you're not why are
you punishing me i'm not punishing you i
know you broke up with me and i'm not
supposed to feel punished who thinks
like that
i don't know i can't i'm sorry i'm sorry
okay me again i i guess i didn't think
it through well it's like too late now i
mean we're dying no it's not too late
megan megan seriously i just i i i i had
a feeling
that i thought was true and clearly
clearly it wasn't true
i'm so confused like are you breaking up
with me are you not bringing up with me
megan i'm not breaking up with you okay
cool so what do you want to do tonight
like i want to hang out with amy and
brad but maybe before that we can go to
angela
[Music]
what just happened
[Music]
oh well thank you i wish i could just
stay at my old place but i can't afford
the new rent yeah moving sucks
you know
strangers handling your belongings the
movers always break something oh no i
can't afford professional movers i'm
moving myself to saturday
[Music]
do you think you can borrow your
roommate's band you can help me with
some of the big stuff
um
yeah
you know what
i've been thinking a lot lately and i
think we need to spend some time apart
not not to break up no i just i just
it's just some time
time apart to
figure ourselves out and and and then
and then we come back together stronger
you know
this is coming out of nowhere no it's
not i've
i have i've tried to tell you like i'm
like a million different ways but you
don't listen see you that's the thing is
that you you never listen i don't need
this time apart for me i need this time
apart for us how long do you think it's
going to take you to move okay this is
about the move you don't want to help me
move wha what
i would i would love to help you move
that's what boyfriends do
claire i just think that it's a weird
coincidence that you need space right
when i'm about to move oh my god
oh my god
i am so sorry that i didn't plan my
emotional turmoil around your move
look at your face see and now you've
assumed the worst of me because you do
that and that's why we need to spend
time apart from each other that is not
fair
not fair
babe all i'm asking for is 12 lousy
hours this saturday okay fine
okay fine
we'll move on sunday 48 hours i don't
know what i was thinking 12 hours
is nowhere near enough time
to do what i
need to do
to make our relationship stronger see
you got me all
confused and you know what i love you
but i gotta get out of here i can't i
just can't i don't
i'm so confused right now i feel like i
can't think and the walls are closing in
on me and i just don't know what to do
oh it's my landlord
he says he doesn't want to lose me as a
tenant so he is not going to raise my
rent
now i don't have to leave my place
and i don't need time apart
because we're perfect together
will you marry me
you paint my apartment
yeah of course i'm painting your
apartment that's what boyfriends do what
when exactly do you think that's going
to happen go go look at that
that's amazing how could it be amazing i
know look at your points
oh
dude you have absolutely mastered this
game well since um
sheila left i've been spending a lot of
time there we go playing the game you're
doing really good thank you
that's why we're here man
help you get over
her
and check out this awesome new game you
have yay
you know i left something in another
room um excuse me everyone
[Music]
yeah
oh he still has the sensors on
i was like him in his room yeah you can
see him that's funny what is he doing
is he is he on his knees does he drop to
his knee oh
no no no no no he's probably looking for
him no look he's he's crying he's crying
oh no he's just
you know he's starting
is he fetal yeah he curled up look at
that he's fetal hey craig buddy
you all right up there oh yeah bob uh
i'm coming right out
[Music]
oh here oh
hey man you all right yes yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah it's just that my sinuses are
acting up yeah
yeah i um i was just you know i was just
thinking about sheila and you know what
i am i am totally over here awesome
awesome let's hey
let's get this party started sure yeah
oh
uh
i forgot to get rid of this picture of
sheila excuse me hey maybe leave the
sensor so one of us can play
oh he's dancing he's dancing with a
photo
is he he's doing he's doing this about
is he kissing it guys we don't i think
he's kissing it you know what i'm going
to turn this off because we don't need
to change it and you die
he's undoing his circle look at this his
pants are coming off his pants are
coming off oh god
yeah no no no no no no no okay that's
happened oh no no no
is he he's he is totally on the bed he's
totally flat on the bed oh maybe he's
shaking a can of hairspray oh gosh
we shouldn't be
okay you know
is he reaching down for his foot i know
he that's his foot isn't it is that
i don't know
and coming back home
i am sorry everybody
would you like me to make some snacks
wash your hands first
oh god yes
i'm here
promise you'll never forget about me
yes
course
promise we will take care of our little
girl
love her
yes
[Music]
promise me you'll stay strong for her
yes
yes
i promise
and promise me you'll never sleep with
another woman
[Music]
i hear you
promise me you'll take care of mr big
fluffy tail yes
yes yes yes
that cat will be
the most loved cat in the world
and that you won't look at porn
no pornography buster brown
says what
is that a yes
yo
better believe i heard washington's hair
girl
you love me right yes i love you yes
and we're soul mates right yes
so you will never
ever ever think of someone else while
masturbating right
message received
i don't understand is that a yes
is that a promise your request has been
filed
say you promise
forget about
huh
i need to hear you say it i
say i pro i promise you promise you
you promise
say it
okay i promise no air quotes
promises
are the things that love
say it
i promise i promise
what are you promising i promise what
you said oh fine forget it yes
i mean
okay
we at least promise to go see my mom
every day
so zero pornography done
i like that
nurse
fix my
[Laughter]
this is wife
all about you
[Music]